les etats unis continuent de vouloir se
soustraire aux réglementations sur les
ventes d'armes
après s'être retirée de plusieurs
traités internationaux et washington
prévoit de contourner un accord datant
de la guerre froide et qui lie 34 pays
objectif vendre plus de drones un large
éventail de clients
françois xavier lambert c'est un accord
de non prolifération qui vise à limiter
les enjambant piloter d'armes de
destruction massive
le régime de contrôle de la technologie
des missiles du rct m
un pacte conclu en 1987 elian 34 nations
dans la continuité de sa politique en
matière d'armement l'administration
trump souhaite assouplir ce traité
objectif permettre à l'industrie
américaine de la défense de vendre plus
de drones armés au reste du monde et
cela concerne notamment des pays du
moyen-orient interdit d'acheter ses
armes dans le cadre actuel
selon le pentagone ces drones pourront
aider les pays alliés des etats unis à
lutter contre le terrorisme et à établir
des contrôles aux frontières
mais cela donnera surtout satisfaction
fabricant de drones américains
confrontés à une concurrence de plus en
plus forte de la part des industriels
chinois israéliens des pays non liés par
le traité rct m
si nous ne sommes pas capables de
répondre à cette demande croissante nous
nous tirons une balle dans le pied
malgré les objections des ong de défense
des droits de l'homme
washington s'est déjà affranchie de
nombreuses réglementations en matière
d'exportations d'armes
donald trump a ainsi retiré les états
unis de plusieurs traités internationaux
notamment celui sur les forces
nucléaires à portée intermédiaire ou
encore le traité dit ciel ouvert un
texte qui permet de vérifier les
mouvements militaires et les mesures de
limitation des armements des pays
signataires d'éventuelles modifications
du régime de contrôle de la technologie
des missiles sera examinée mardi
prochain par le conseil de sécurité
nationale de la maison blanche